eu sou pesquisador sou biólogo e hoje eu
gostaria de compartilhar a minha visão
do papel da criatividade na ciência
eu tenho 42 anos estão também nessa
idade que você vai perguntando coisas
existenciais porque nós estamos aqui que
dá sentido para nossas vidas
e quando você pensa sobre essa pergunta
básica
uma das coisas imediatas são as nossas
ligações afetivas
a primeira coisa que dá sentido pra
nossas vidas são nossos amigos as
pessoas que nós amamos nossa família
nossos filhos nossos pais
isso é a parte fácil fora disso que que
realmente dá sentido para nossas vidas
tem uma coisa que eu sinto
particularmente importantes são coisas
bonitas belezas que eu quero dizer com
isso por exemplo você na frente do mar
no fim da tarde
você fica na frente desse espectáculo e
realmente é uma beleza tão grande que
você se sente existir mais intensamente
não é isso funciona com qualquer tipo de
beleza natural na montanha ao mar
você está na frente dessa espectáculo e
você se sente incluído nesse todo isso é
difícil de explicar mas dá pra gente um
a sensação de existir dá um sentido
mesmo não dá pra explicar muito bem
porquê mas é tão intenso é essa a
sensação que eu acho que todo mundo todo
mundo concorda sobre isso agora tem
outros tipos de belezas por exemplo tem
belezas que xavi que eu chamo de
construídas
o exemplo mais simples são as artes as
artes on 1 coisas bonitas obras de athos
pinturas esculturas prédios
arquitectónicos bonitos e quando você
vai num museu tem algumas obras de arte
que tocam essas coisas tão bem ela tinha
é refletir uma coisa tão forte uma
emoção tão intensa que você se sente
existe um pouco mais se as obras da de
arte ela aumenta nossa existência e
okami pega mais
eu o artista o artist essa pessoa muito
especial que consegue capturar uma
emoção e traduzir essa emoção numa obra
de arte pode ser uma dança pode ser uma
uma pintura essa essa capacidade de
capturar uma coisa bonita é extremamente
especial é na verdade faz séculos que a
gente está tentando entender como esse
processo existe e porque são só poucas
pessoas que conseguem fazer isso eu acho
incrível mas a vida do artista não é uma
vida fácil na verdade que faz o artista
ele vai procurar esses momentos
especiais onde ele consegue capturar não
é um eu acredito que não vê um processo
contínuo
você vai ser luta 70 trabalhar e de
repente você acha uma coisa se entendi
uma coisa e por isso que eu vejo um
paralelo muito grande com os cientistas
pesquisadores
eu sei que isso não é a visão comum da
pesquisa científica não é visão comum
que as pessoas têm dos pesquisadores os
pesquisadores são pessoas sérias frias
rígidas
é a ciência é difícil não é mas quem é
pesquisador
aqui eu tenho certeza vai concordar
comigo o pesquisador
ele tem essa mesma capacidade de
capturar coisas bonitas
vou dar um exemplo o newtom todo mundo
conhece um minuto um físico britânico
famoso que formulou a lei da gravitação
universal
no fim do século 17 que colocou no
tumulto fez
a primeira coisa que ele fez e que ele
ele fez
ele observou que quando você deixa um
objeto cair um objeto vai para baixo
ele fez essa pergunta porque é que ele
vai para baixo porque quando você deixa
uma maçã cair a não vai pra cima o do
lado parece bobo né
mas isso é uma pergunta genial tanto com
newton na verdade era o primeiro
há realmente fazer essa pergunta no isso
apenas isso uma boa pergunta uma grande
pergunta essa pergunta quando você faz
uma pergunta e isso é verdade do nilton
mas qualquer pesquisador faz esse tipo
de pergunta o trabalho do pesquisador é
exatamente isso fazer uma grande
pergunta fazer uma grande pergunta não
tem a ver com o rigor não tem a ver com
o sério não tem a ver com uma intuição
quem vai fazer essa pergunta exatamente
a mesma coisa cortes pensando um como
que eu vou traduzir a emoção eu acho que
essa pintura
essa cor essa textura vai dar melhor
fazer uma grande pergunta é uma coisa
absolutamente genial ele faz essa
pergunta porque é que as coisas caiam
ele vai caminhando com essa pergunta aí
vem um segundo momento genial é que ele
vai entender que na verdade o objeto não
cai
o objeto tá sendo atraído pela terra o
planeta e se isso que a gravitação
universal na verdade o planeta terra
ele está sendo atraído pela pela maçã o
pelo objeto e objeto também só o planeta
é tão grande que nem ver quando ele
entende isso e vamos pensar um pouco
imagina o que quer dizer isso um cara
ver um objeto cair pensa um eu acho que
tem uma atração com a terra
nesse momento não tem pensamento
rigoroso
em pensamento racional tem uma intuição
eu quero dizer hoje e que o trabalho de
pesquisa científica e primeiro um
trabalho de intuição
você tem a intuição que talvez esse
objeto está caindo nessa direção
porque embaixo tem um objeto muito
grande que você nem pensa que tá tá indo
todos os outros objetos e por isso que
se você deixa um objeto que aqui ou no
japão os dois vão para baixo mas na
verdade a direção dos dois é diferente
eles vão direção do centro da terra
depois vem um momento que eu acho lindo
que você vai ter que provar que a sua
intuição tá certa está correta
e aí tem na ciência tem um caminho só
que o caminho do rigor o rigor de novo
parece uma coisa fria difícil seca mas é
lógico rigor uma coisa absolutamente
bonita tem uma elegância no rigor o que
eu recorrer ao método uma língua
internacional qualquer pesquisador
científico no mundo independente da
língua que ele fala e entende o record
aí que você vai ter que fazer você vai
ter que pegar sua intuição e você vai
ter que usar o caminho do rigor é igual
a uma densa tem passos que você pode
fazer tem passos que você não pode fazer
do jeito nenhum e esse caminho pode ser
muito longo
ele pode usar tem pessoas que falam que
ele pode ser sofrido mas eu acho que ele
é bonito então que o trabalho do
pesquisador no final muito parecido como
o trabalho tô do artista o pesquisador
não trabalha pra acumular conhecimento o
artista também não trabalha pra acumular
obras de arte
ele trabalha ele corre atrás
nesses momentos muitos especiais onde
você percebe uma coisa entendi uma coisa
pela primeira vez nossa armação está
sendo atraído pela terra e depois ele
vai caminhando nesse caminho do rigor
nessa língua muito especial
o universal e você vai ter que de que
você tem que provar para o resto do
mundo que a sua intuição ela estava
correto correto no caso do nilton a
intuição dele provou extremamente
correta até o início do século 20 onde
ainda está em mostrou que em algum em
alguns casos não funcionava mas é isso a
beleza da da ciência então o que eu
quero dizer pra vocês hoje e que o
trabalho da pesquisa científica contra é
diferente da da noção que todo mundo tem
não é um trabalho muito difícil muito
duro muito seco e muito frio e um
trabalho muito especial ele muito
parecido como o trabalho artístico no
sentido que ele vai muito pela intuição
você tem que ter atenção então vamos
pensar sobre a ciência como um um
trabalho muito bonito essa intuição é
linda e nesse sentido ela dá um sentido
muito forte para a sua vida como
pesquisador
mas ela também dá um sentido muito fofa
quinta vendo isso de fora é tanto
convidando vocês hoje
aaaah ver a ciência como o valor
extremamente porta se engaja a entender
que o pensamento científico que não esse
pensamento tudo frio que todo mundo acha
um pensamento lindo eu gostaria muito de
ressaltar essa noção que um valor tão
importante como as artes e que ele
precisa sair do laboratório para mostrar
esse caminho de construção artístico
quase artístico intuitiva e do rigor
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]